Luffy might be in trouble because the
wantis manga is quickly about to reach
the climax of The Egghead island arc and
this chapter just gave us hints of how
the final battle is truly going to play
out which includes the PowerHouse
matchups including gear 5 Luffy against
the shadow clone Jutsu Admiral kizaru
the awakened Luchi vs Zorro and Saint
Saturn against probably everyone else
but that's not all because with most of
the major characters coming together on
the bottom part of the island whatever
climactic event we were promised to
happen is surely about to blow up and
turn this Arc into the match that sets
the final Sagar Ablaze but of course to
start we first have to talk about Luffy
versus kizaru because as I hoped the
Marine Admiral is not just gonna be
completely overwhelmed by gear 5 Luffy
in fact what I never expected was to see
kizadu bust out a shadow clone Jutsu and
make a bunch of clones of him self out
of light in order to take out Luffy in
fact up to now he honestly seems to be
pretty much completely unfaced in
general by year 5 Luffy apparently being
the only person to be fully resistant to
Luffy's cartoon powers and even easily
outsmarting Luffy by distracting him
with the Clones yeah not the first time
that we've seen Luffy being outsmarted
but it does make me wonder if we and
possibly Luffy as well have been
somewhat underestimating kizanu a little
bit I mean this man is a marine Admiral
who confidently asked if he should go to
wano to handle kaido and big mom
together so maybe we should be wondering
just how desperate the situation is for
Luffy and the crew instead of the other
way around but also before we get into
all of that in three days it will be
five insane years since I actually
started this Channel and tonight at 8pm
eastern time I'm dropping this very
special piece of merchandise that I've
been secretly working on with apari then
I'm just super proud of it's this
insanely cool Japanese knee style jacket
and they're actually only going to be
100 pieces of this sold ever 50 per
color variation so if you want to
support the channel and celebrate with
me in style the link for these will be
in the description first come first
serve and now back to the chapter and
while I'm of course gonna dive deeper
into the fights in this chapter in just
a moment first I do have one more major
question about kizaru's new clone Powers
I mean we've seen many many devil fruit
users create clones before like when the
strings would use a doflamingo made a
clone to tank this hit and we've of
course got Nico Robin who makes tons of
clones that she can even control but
both of these characters ate paramecia
type devil fruits which allow them to
control the substance that they produce
however that is not the case for kizuru
and as far as we know lokia fruits have
only ever been able to shoot out their
Elemental abilities not really control
them for example the lightning fruit
user NL could launch massive bolts of
electricity and Admiral Akino of course
can blast people's Face Off With His
magmaphys but creating separate clones
that can act on their own that is
something we've honestly never really
seen before from a logo user and I'm
super curious to see what level of
control kizaru actually has over these
for example is he somehow controlling
the light or are they independent beings
physically that can actually act on
their own or are they basically just
light projections kind of like the
Holograms that we saw earlier in this
Arc plus we do have to ask how this is
even possible in the first place since
we've never seen it happen before and
who knows maybe it's just some form of
his light fruit Awakening or it could
just be some very special ability of the
light devil fruit I mean I honestly
cannot wait to find out because this
seems fairly broken and kind of seems to
have nothing to do with his power so far
now despite how incredibly cool kizaru
looks showing off even more of his
awesome abilities I do have to say that
I'm actually pretty disappointed in the
direction that this fight seems to be
going and that's because at least to me
please let me know if you feel
differently but it kind of looks like
hisaru is not 100 interested in actually
fighting Luffy if you know what I mean
instead he kind of keeps going after his
different objectives like when he tried
to attack vegapung last chapter and in
this one again likewise Luffy is busy
trying to protect his friends instead of
going all out against the Admiral which
by the way that shot of him taking in
kizaru's light and splitting it like
some kind of prism was just really
awesome creme de La Creme panel right
there but besides that I'm just getting
a really bad feeling that this fight is
going to end with the straw hats and
some allies escaping instead of this
like all-out actual Clash yonko vs
Admiral that me personally and probably
also you were really hoping for however
on the other hand and hear me out here
it might actually be a good thing
because we definitely won't be getting a
long drawn out fight like we would
expect from a major battle just like
this I mean do I need to remind you of
the 49 chapter Marathon like Luffy vs
kaido and ultimately this means that we
should be getting to the promised epic
finale of this Arc and then to elbaf
even faster and kind of put the entire
versus Admiral Saga a little bit later
in the story nonetheless there is still
plenty of fighting actually going on in
this chapter though and in particular
one major Clash is of course Zorro
against the now fully awakened once
again leopard user Lucci and I'm
personally honestly super excited to see
how Zoro now Stacks up against the
government secret agents because if gear
5 Luffy absolutely destroyed Luchi then
zaro's performance against Luchi should
give us a pretty decent idea of how
current Zorro actually compares to Luffy
now of course we do have to consider the
small chance that Zorro actually loses
this battle but honestly I would be
shocked and disappointed if that were to
occur I mean even in his awakened form I
really don't think that Luchi is
stronger than kaido's right-hand man
king and if you remember members are all
basically one-shotted King once he
finally learned how to control his newly
awakened Advanced conquerors hockey
although Luchi is probably a little bit
more of a backstabbing ruthless fighter
than King so who knows maybe he will use
some sort of dirty tricks instead of
fighting Zoro straight out in a true
one-on-one which he's gonna have to see
and while we're speculating about the
future here this is also the perfect
time to recap the possibility of the
Vega punks leaving the islands with the
straw hat because in fact in this
chapter jimbei can even be seen taking a
bunch of vegapung's gear towards the
Thousand Sunny so it does seem like
there's a pretty good possibility that
at least one of the mega punks will
actually be coming along though we do
know what happened with oh also in case
you forgot here are the latest updates
on all seven Vega punks we know from
chapter 1090 that Chaka and patagaras
were confirmed to be actually dead
although you know how that is in one
piece will of p and everything then we
have the bite-sized Edison who is still
in the control room with nami usab and
the traitor York next is Lilith who is
currently piloting Frankie's giant Mech
carrying the straw hat ship to the back
of the island and that just really
leaves us with Atlas And the main body
vegapunk who has driven this awesome
Vega tank all the way to the battlefield
in order to order the pacifistas back to
their side which I was kind of hoping
that he would be able to do however with
all of them still scattered around the
island like this it's honestly really
hard to tell how many if any of these
Vega punks will actually survive slash
make it on board of the Thousand Sunny
but if I had to bet on at least one I
would say that Lilith will be the one to
go with the straw hat since not only has
she been there the longest but she's
also the one who has been with the ship
all this time as well but of course I
simply cannot go any longer without
sharing this awesome theory about the
main Vega Punk which actually makes a
ton of sense for the Epic finale of the
end of this Arc so okay so hear me out
because as we've discussed before quite
often the eckhead island arc has a lot
of parallels to previous arcs like
Marine forts Eva ODI and so on and so
forth but one can connection I have not
heard disgust as much are the
similarities to the island of Ohara
which we saw during Robin's flashback on
that island there was a ton of
information such as Research into the
pony glyphs that the world government
didn't want anyone to share with the
rest of the world so let's bring this
all back to Egghead Island now because
we have the reverse situation where
vegapunk has a ton of top secret
information that he most likely doesn't
want to fall into the world government's
hands and on top of that he also knows
about the pony glyphs and the ancient
Kingdom so I can just imagine that as
the straw hats escape the main vegapunk
does two things first he sends out
information about the ancient Kingdom to
the entire world completing the work
that was started once on O'Hara he could
probably do this using the punk records
which is kind of like the internet of
the one piece world and secondly I can
very easily see vegapunk pushing a
self-destruct button or something like
that to destroy the entire island of
Egghead just like the world government
destroyed O'Hara really he would
probably do this to prevent the world
government from getting their hands on
the mother flame energy source that they
need to power their super weapon that
can destroy entire islands and if this
sounds too crazy for you remember that
vegapunk installed a self-destruct
button on his previous lap on Punk
Hazard as well so it's actually not that
insane to think that he has one here as
well and on the other hand that
mind-blowing situation no pun intended
is exactly of course what kizaru and
Saint Saturn would want to prevent under
all circumstances because although this
would most likely accomplish their goal
of killing vegapunk it would mean that
the other two main objectives of
obtaining the mother flame and rescuing
York are probably ruins and who knows
maybe Saint Saturn might even be caught
up in the explosion which would be an
even bigger shock to the world and
speaking of Saint Saturn here his brief
but kind of ominous appearance at the
end of this chapter hopefully does mean
that he will be joining the action soon
I mean and so the only question is is
what will this man be doing well let's
break it down because no matter what way
you look at it it absolutely must be a
part of the Epic conclusion that we were
told about that would end Egghead
islands and of course the first and most
obvious thing that he can actually do is
retake control of the pacifista after
the vegapunks took them over this
chapter again which by the way I have to
ask where are most of the set of him at
this point I mean I do know that they
were locked up in bubbles a few chapters
ago but wouldn't it make sense for them
to join the battle if they're commanded
by vegapunk now or maybe they should
stay locked up in bubbles to keep them
from flipping sides once again and
honestly I do hate to add on to the
negative takes in this review but I'm
starting to get pretty tired of this
whole set of theme and passifista's
flipping sides all the time thing
because when these warlord clones were
introduced there was so much hype
surrounding these characters but all
that hype is absolutely gone at this
point because one chapter there allies
and then in the next their enemies I
mean yeah they are super super strong
but then they were also taken out in one
go by Bubble so far so yeah although the
one side of this that I would absolutely
love to see is the seraphim somehow
managing to gain control of themselves
which totally fits in with all the talk
in recent chapters about being slaves to
the government for example kizaru feels
like he has to follow orders and Kuma
used to be a world government slave as
well so uh wouldn't it be great if the
ones who literally have to follow
commands and have allegedly no free will
could somehow manage to break free
especially with Luffy there anyways uh
ran over subscribe to the channel and
now let's get back to sane Saturn now it
would be easy of course for him to
command the Posse fiestas because of the
command structure that we were shown
earlier in this Arc but besides that I
do need for Saturn to finally show off
the mysterious powers that we first saw
back in chapter 1085 because in case you
forgot I mean not sure how but in case
you did Saturn appears to have this kind
of bull-like transformation with these
giant horns here and now we don't know
if this is an actual devil fruit power
or something else but I just have to
learn more about it and what more
perfect timing than the end of this arc
when there is short to be a massive
conflict and speaking of conflict Sanji
who's been kind of robbed a fight so far
might actually be the first one to have
to face off against San Saturn because
he's currently with the main Vega Punk
and the pacifista so how will Sanji
respond to seeing one of the Elder Stars
will he jump straight into an attack or
will he be busy fighting the passifista
or will someone else come and make a
mess out of this entire fight as well
honestly we've talked about it before
this would be the perfect time for the
Blackbeard Pirates to finally make their
appearance although it would also be the
perfect opportunity for them to go after
the rubbings of the opponent lifts on
the sunny that's because it's basically
only protected by Lilith and jimbei at
this point or an even crazier option
might be if someone like the Marine
hunting organization cross Guild showed
up and truly shocked the World by taking
out one of the godosei on their own like
man that would be insane plus it would
give us the chance to see Luffy and
buggy finally reunite again which
honestly I just love these characters so
much that I made an entire video
explaining how stupidly powerful Luffy
would be with a second devil fruit
including buggies surprisingly
overpowered Chop Chop fruit and if you
want to see just how insane things get
with some of these super wild
combinations you can watch that video
right here thanks for watching as always
was a really fun chapter and I will see
you in the next one